He did it.
He did it this morning.
We've been warning about this for months.
Donald Trump this morning suggested that the
2020 presidential election be delayed.
He is doing it.
This is not a dress rehearsal.
This is happening.
It's not happening yet.
I mean, he's trying to do it.
I get the authoritarian chills when I read
the tweet.
Donald Trump tweeted this morning with universal
mail in voting, not absentee voting, which
is good.
2020 will be the most inaccurate and fraudulent
election in history.
It will be a great embarrassment to the United
States of America.
DeLay the election until people can properly,
securely and safely vote.
The president of the United States is actually
suggesting that an election which he might
lose by historic margins to Joe Biden should
be delayed, postponed.
The president is trying to do the thing they
said Obama would do.
Remember 2012 and 2016?
The conspiracy, right.
Insisted Barack Obama is a Marxist, dictatorial,
authoritarian nightmare.
Who is going to declare martial law, send
troops to cities and suspend the election
in order to stay in power indefinitely?
Barack Obama was never going to do any of
those things.
Donald Trump has sent armed paramilitaries
to cities around the United States.
And Donald Trump has now suggested that the
presidential election be delayed.
He wants to delay an election prescribed by
the constitution.
This is a constitutional issue.
This is a red alert.
It is no surprise that today we got the worst
GDP numbers since World War Two.
And Donald Trump's polling continues to implode.
And Trump says, you know, we should look at
delaying the election.
We have never had anything like this.
It's very tempting to say this is unprecedented.
We've never seen a we have not had anything
like this.
My hope is that this backfires and Trump loses
Republican support.
I'm right here waiting for the Republicans
that call themselves constitutional conservatives.
Come out and denounce this.
I'm waiting for you.
Make me proud.
I'm ready.
This is actually closing in on the fascistic
characteristics that they attributed to Barack
Obama, which never existed.
We cannot allow this to happen.
And by the way, how is it safe to open schools
and have teachers and students there for eight
hours a day?
But it's not safe to go vote, which, depending
on where you live.
Takes two minutes, five minutes, 10 minutes,
15 minutes.
And it can be done by mail making that argument
irrelevant anyway.
Now, as a side note, Trump says universal
mail in voting is bad, but absentee would
be OK this time around.
All that we're talking about, all that states
have done, many states, is expand absentee
voting to anybody who wants to do it.
It is not some new or different system that
would be ripe for open to fraud.
It is not that this is an attack on the foundation
of the country and an attack on democracy.
Can Donald Trump do it?
Well, it's actually not up to him.
The good news is that it is not up to Donald
Trump to delay the election.
If states wanted to, you could delay the elections
somewhat.
But I think that by mid-December, the electors
have to decide who are their votes going to.
And if you don't have a new president elected
on January 21st.
Again, my understanding from speaking to some
constitutional experts is Trump.
If Trump does, if you don't have an election
and Trump has not been reelected on January
20th, rather, he's no longer the president.
And it would go to the speaker of the House,
which would be Nancy Pelosi, which I can't
imagine Donald Trump wants.
But this is going to be a question of do any
governors agree?
Is there any governor?
Republicans only I would assume that will
even consider saying I think Trump might be
up to something that makes sense here.
I think we should delay the election.
Or will all governors say we're doing the
election?
And that's basically it.
Now, in the in the coming hours, every Republican
that is interviewed on corporate media should
be asked.
Donald Trump suggested delaying the presidential
election.
Do you think that we should do it?
Put every single one of them on the record,
watch some of them start to equivocate.
Well, you know, I. I didn't see the tweet.
I'd have to see what it is that Donald Trump
wants to do.
I can't hear you.
I think I think our connection is bad.
Simple, yes or no.
Should we delay the election, start putting
them on record?
This is not practice.
This is the game.
This is this is where it's happening right
now.
And he is doing it and.
It is absolutely horrifying.